your home at a premium price obviously  possibly offering for in this  neighborhood $20 making on the whole  gentrification thing is I think timely  because that's what happens you know we  all went out to the suburbs and now  we're moving back to the city so there's  neighborhoods that were given up to the  PO folk are now being taken back by the  people with money we'd seen this sort of  status quo of their poverty and now what  does that poverty look like when it's  putting up against people with  disposable income living a few houses  away while you would think would be  straightforwardly a great thing to have  a park to have people start taking care  of their yards to have a nice cafe but  it's interesting how people can actually  rebel against that not only just on  principle but on the fact that it's  actually kind of making the neighborhood  too expensive for them